so I want to revisit this topic of
everyone needs to drink more water I
know last time I did a video on this uh
stirred up a lot of um opinions on this
topic so before you click off just
please hear me out I will say right up
front that I do drink water and I'm not
against water I drink about 2 and a half
liters of water every single day however
there's some really interesting
information about water because you may
think that water hydrates you it
actually doesn't it could even
dehydrates you and I'm primarily talking
about drinking excessive amounts of
water there's a term for this it's
called water intoxication or water
poisoning or overhydration because if
you think about it how does this water
get into your cells is it a passive
thing does it just kind of go into your
cells and start
hydrating no there are very specific
proteins that allow this water to go
into your cells and with the help of
electrolytes and so what happens when
you drink drink a lot of water without
electrolytes you can dilute the body's
electrolytes mainly sodium but other
electrolytes as well and that condition
is called hypo nmia and here are the
symptoms Headache
nausea confusion irritability muscle
cramping as well as brain swelling
there's even a condition called e a
that's a condition where the person is
water logged okay and it's creating a
lot of swelling in the brain and that
could easily come from just drinking too
much water and this often occurs when
someone is exercising and so this really
pertains to athletes and people that
exercise a lot especially people that do
marathons and they're drinking a lot of
water it could be quite dangerous in
fact in the uh Boston uh Marathon uh
2005 at the end of the Finish Line they
actually detected
133% of everyone that crossed the Finish
Line had this hyponatremia which is
basically a diluted fluid in your body
where you don't have enough uh sodium
now there's other things that also can
cause hyponatremia other than just
drinking too much water it could be that
you had diarrhea vomiting you're just
sweating too much because think about it
like when you sweat uh it's really salty
and then also if you're drinking a lot
of plain water without salt you're just
going to create a situation where you're
going to actually be very deficient in
salt just as a side note one of the
first symptoms of a salt or a sodium
deficiency is uh muscle weakness okay
you feel very very weak and this could
easily occur if you're doing some type
of sport or exercising and just you feel
like your your muscles are weaker and
weaker well obviously you need more salt
and some people that have these sports
drinks uh might not have enough salt or
other electrolytes in them instead they
might have a few electrolytes and a lot
of glucose which by the way can tie up a
lot of these electrolytes especially
potassium it kind of locks it up there's
another condition where a person is they
have very weak adrenal right the
adrenals are very very weak and that's
called Addison and that person can't
hold sodium and so that person is very
susceptible to having this hyponatremia
situation so people that have that
condition need to consume a lot of salt
uh just to balance out the fluids now
also when someone drinks alcohol a lot
of beer you know I remember one time I
was in high school and I drank a case of
beer which is very very dangerous and of
course I didn't drink any with that so
that created a major imbalance with my
electrolytes and my brain felt like it
was going to explode because that's what
happens when you actually have this
hypon nutras you get swelling in the
brain you also have those that have a
hypothyroid condition you have people
that are on diuretics which can really
throw off your electrolytes because it's
meant to get rid of this sodium and the
person is usually on a low sodium diet
you see I really think there's more
problems with uh having low sodium than
High sodium and by the way if you do
consume a lot of sodium you can always
balance out that with more potassium
people who are salt sensitive are really
potassium deficient infants are also
susceptible to having this
hyponatremia uh situation people who are
on uh ssris um are susceptible as well
and diabetics are also susceptible to
having this situation because of the
different fluid electrolyte imbalances
and also uh they have higher sugar and
they're going to be peeing out more
fluid and so they can easily be
dehydrated so drinking more water is not
the only cause of this hypon nutrium if
the person has diarrhea or is vomiting
or is exercising and sweating all these
salts out or is on certain medications
that can be also creating a situation
you'd want to advise them to also add
sodium and not go crazy with too much
water so if you're checked out on this
video check back in because this next
thing I want to tell you is very very
important there has been deaths uh
occurring from people drinking about six
liters of water okay within a 3-hour
period what is 6 lers of fluid that is
1.5 gallons okay I mean I'm sure you've
known people who have Dr just guzzled a
gallon of water in one sitting very
quickly not smart when I was in the
military um we when I would March 17
miles right we' drink a tremendous
amount of water we'd also take salt with
that typically now uh at least in the
military when you're training uh the
most that you're supposed to drink per
hour is 1 to 1.5 lers of fluid per hour
so you don't want to drink way too much
fluid too fast even if you're sweating
now of course on the flip side if you're
susceptible to kidney stones you should
be drinking at least 2 and A2 liters of
fluid a day even if you're not thirsty
but the point is you do want to pay
attention to your thirst and drink when
you're thirsty and not go crazy with too
much but I think 2 to 2 and A2 liters of
fluid is totally reasonable and of
course if you're doing exercise or doing
marathons you really want to make sure
you don't create this condition called
hypon nmia where you're just guzzling
all this water um with very little
electrolytes the last point I'm going to
make which is very important if you're
exercising and you're sweating and
you're taking a regular electrolyte
powder that's not necessar neily meant
for sports or exercise you might want to
either add more sodium to that
electrolyte or use some type of sport
hydration electrolyte with more sodium
now because of the censoring and the
suppressing of the algorithms on YouTube
it's becoming more difficult to find my
content and there's a lot of content
that I cannot put on YouTube
unfortunately so to make sure you have
full access of all my information go to
drberg.com And subscribe to my
newsletter by clicking the link Down
Below in the description I will see you
on the other side now I actually created
another uh very popular video on
hydration if you haven't seen this one
check it
out